good evening ladies and gentlemen thank
you for joining us this evening for the
community building through participatory
design webinar
my name is amira i'm from participate in
design and i'll be our emcee for today
to everyone joining us on facebook if
you'd like to join us on zoom
please click on the link in the comment
section the webinar today is organized
by participating design
supported by design singapore council
and national design center
in partnership with be fantastic a tech
art initiative
colors collectively hours in shophouse
and co this event is also part of the
national design center's program lineup
in august and september
with a demanding focus on singapore our
home
before we proceed i would like to take a
while to highlight a few house rules
which you can see on your screen
currently
do note that this session will be
recorded all participants order will
automatically be unmute
if you have any questions do submit them
in the q a module
and we apologize in advance if you are
not able to answer all your questions
but we will try our best to answer the
commonly asked questions
and if you are facing any technical
issues at all feel free to reach out to
us via the chat module
during this webinar audio will be on
mute so click on the relevant
images on the bottom of your webinar
panel to click to click to connect to
audio
let us know as well if you're facing any
technical issues raise hands and you
should be unneeded to speak
and answer questions here so we are less
likely to miss it
with this we would like to kick off this
evening's program by giving you a little
context about the webinar itself
the question that we're asking through
this webinar is how might we rethink
design as a process that could bring
communities together
so this webinar 60 rediscover design is
a community building tool
as community practitioners and design
experts share how participatory design
tools and methodology
can be used in our local context to
co-create public and social spaces
without further ado allow me to
introduce the moderator of this webinar
ms stella gui
so stella is not just the co-founder of
shophouse and co she is also a publicist
marketer and event producer with over 15
years of industrial experience dealing
with arts and entertainment
she's an every traveler who is
passionate about music culture films and
communities
and is always burning with ideas to help
creatives turn their ideas into reality
while still ensuring that projects are
sustainable for the long run
stella over to you thank you amira
hi everyone welcome to today's webinar
um and i heard that uh we have quite a
lot of people who sign up and they are
from all over the world
so wherever you are in the world thank
you thank you for taking this precious
two hours of your time
um to join us today so i'm really really
glad um to have with uh me today as our
sd panelist
um to join us and to talk about
participatory design
and how can design play a role in
building communities and create
a sense of home yeah so let me just
introduce my
um my panelists again today they are dr
chong king founding partner colors
collectively ours
associate professor singapore university
of technology and design
mr larry yoon uh executive director
participate in design and miss kamiya
ramachandran
founder of be fantastic attack art
initiative
yeah so um before we get the presenters
to share
uh i want us to just have a look at the
question again
um if lexi could put it up yeah the
question is how
can design play a role in building
communities and
create a sense of home you know we all
know what this period has been 2020 has
brought us
really really strange times and most of
us have actually ironically been
um stuck at home working from home and
and and having our social life confined
to the space of our home right so
i wanted to just um have a sense of what
this mean you know like what is the
sense of home that we are talking about
you know sometimes often we get very
carried away in a process
and in a methodology and of the work we
do that we actually forget
what is this thing we are trying to do
here right what's the sense of home
you know um so i'm gonna have to check
any of our speakers before they go to
the presentation
but i want our viewers or our audience
to just just kind of
run through and think through can this
sense of home actually be created
you know shouldn't this process be very
very spontaneous and natural
right and what are the missing
ingredients or factors
that actually will have um a community
lose
that sense right so um i want to just
begin by
speaking and before i bring my speakers
on um my panel is have you ever felt
a strong sense of home maybe now or
maybe in the past when you were used to
live in
a different neighborhood or different
community you know or a different city
um or did you feel that there is this
sudden loss to that sense of home that
you had experienced
maybe we can begin we come here come
here we heard you just moved to
singapore welcome
to singapore and we're really very happy
that you've joined us
yeah so yeah thank you stella
yeah i think uh sense of home is not
just about the house that we are
trapped in i think for me the sense of
home begins
when there is peace and security within
the home but when you start
reaching out to beyond the home and
making connections and networks
when you have a friendly chat with a
neighbor and i think
coved has amplified that a lot for us
when you see people
in the italian balconies strumming their
guitar and kind of serenading out to
somebody across
a balcony far away you realize that
sense of home is really these
connections
of people to other people and not really
the physicality of your home
thank you kamiyah how about uh larry and
uh yeah quinoa anything too i
i grew up in malaysia i came to
singapore when i was
still quite young i'll say teenage time
so and since then i make singapore my
home and i i think i
totally agree with is it's not just a
house but it's about
your most intimate connection with the
people around you
right you connect with your family
that's why you make the home
as part of your family space but you
also connect with your neighbors you
connect with your
uh larger community so uh even
uh you know strangers sometimes that you
make the kind of
uh when you come down to the void deck
for example you go to the market and you
go
or at the leave right and and once a
while you you see
these people and then you start to say
hi and that's where i do you get a sense
that you are connected
i think all these are very important uh
for for all of us
yeah larry
what about you you didn't grow up in
singapore but you actually
not a lot of people know but you
actually didn't grow up in singapore and
what's that like yeah yeah and then i
totally agree with kim
because you know for me the sense of
home is really other than connection
with people it's also about culture
because i mean uh i stayed abroad for a
period of time
and you know whenever i hear singlish or
singaporeans talking to one another you
know
i think immediately the sense of home
comes in and i feel right at home you
know even though i'm not in singapore so
i do agree with quincy you know it's the
connection between people
they really bring about their sense of
home maybe
since larry brought up culture i think
food is another thing that i always
have a very strong sense of how their
tyson when i was
uh living in uh us uh for a year doing
my steam
at mit with my family uh we always
looking forward to the weekend so they
can look out for some of the
food the asian food or even singaporean
food or prata you know
these are the things that you bring back
to a kind of sense of home that you can
connect with
nice yes totally a king i agree with you
food is definitely the glue
in many many many cities yeah well i
i'm curious as well for audience so i i
just had a quick poll
uh you know everyone felt that they they
feel a strong
sense of home but i'm just curious does
anybody oh
well that's fast you know whether they
feel very strongly connected to where
you live
or actually not really you know it's
like you don't know your neighbors you
you're kind of not sure like uh what
does that even mean
you know strong sense of home and
connection
so i i just lift this running for a
little bit and this is really
you know the crux of what we're
discussing today right before we get
into sharing a project
and all that i would like us to i'm
getting this discussion to kind of
check now we have a very strong yes so
pretty good we have 67 percent who feel
a strong sense of home and connection to
where you live
and about 33 yeah so feel free to
you know continue to share maybe i did a
question and answer or in the chat
some of uh uh your your comments and
stuff like that
with us or why you don't or why you do
right and
the second question i have will be
have you ever felt you lost your
connection to the city
the neighborhood or the home that you
live in
you know we we all had grown up in you
know at least for us in singapore
sometimes our neighborhood
um had a lot of development and changes
quite quickly over a short span of time
we are a young city after all um so yeah
i just wanted to just have an idea
do you ever felt that you don't
recognize a city when you
come back or your neighborhood or even
your own home
you might go like abroad for some
holiday and came home man like hey
what happened to my house is so my home
is different
okay so not quite balanced so
we had about a large number to say that
they
also had felt a loss in the connection
so yeah this is quite balanced it's very
interesting
i think there is a strong sense of
connection to
a home but at the same time there's
quite a large percentage of us who had
experienced this loss and connection to
the city
and to the neighborhood and so i just
wanted to just have this little exercise
to
to just you know have us to be a bit
mindful of what we're discussing today
all right and and actually i have given
our
our three speakers a little homework
earlier this week
um i told them hey you guys are all
designers aren't you training
architecture which means you can sketch
you can
you know draw and things like so i've
given them this little mini activity and
any time throughout this one hour if you
feel like oh god i draw
you know i'm i'm kind of like losing my
attention span
maybe you can try this exercise at home
or where you are all right so in today's
discussion you're going to
hear a lot about this um uh action words
like you know building creating
connecting you know and
and as well as keywords like community
home
you know design so i've actually asked
my my three panelists
today to illustrate or you know in any
form it means there can be a sketch a
venn diagram
flowchart whatever they feel that
best represent their work as well as
their value
to the question that we will begin and
later on after the sharing after the q a
we will wrap this session
um with what they had and i have a i had
a teaser to it and they have some
powerful stuff that they will be sharing
okay so now let's um not let's carry on
and let's begin with our first speaker
king hua
so kinwa he is the principal
investigator of
social urban research group and
co-leader of opportunity lab at sutd
he is also the founding partner of
colors collectively hours llp
specializing in collaborative public
space
public place design so today um he's
going to share with us a very exciting
presentation
titled participatory design as creative
activism
so king hua please blow our mind and i
will learn
this wonderful session to begin with
your presentation
king hua over to you thank you stella
uh i hope i live up to the expectation
yeah we started colors collectively
hours
you know colors actually acronym for
these two words collectively hours
uh a couple of years ago together with
my partner
fong ing who is a landscape architect
i'm trained as an architect
so uh we thought that when we came back
to uh
singapore over a short stint in the
state that we realized that there's a
lot more
that architect and landscape architect
and designer can do
so we started without actually having
any projects we just want to do
something
and and and since then never look back
and there's
so many things that i think we can do
even more uh to see how we can bring
community
together and create a sense of home but
our core values
is this faulting diverse diversity
empowerment adaptability and resilience
so
that would uh you know throughout our
project we will show that yeah
so uh since there's a quite a number of
international audience today i heard
i just want to give a bit of context why
are we working on those
community spaces i think singapore is
well known for its
clean uh and need kind of streetscape
urban scape high rise
you know you look on the left you see
this kind of very new high-rise
public housing um you know
it's comparable to a condominium that
you know
many parts of the world that people
living in right but when we come to
uh spaces on the ground uh then we look
start to see different kind of uh
somewhat
uh sometimes uh contrasting kind of
image
sometimes it's uh you know it's a void
spaces
sometimes spaces where people
appropriate in their own way
some of the social spaces are more
functional than others
so we start to think can we as designer
also
you know bring a sense of place a sense
or ownership
into some some of these places as well
at the
you know at the corners or community
spaces that we see
in every day so that's how uh we started
questioning
but it actually came back uh
uh quite some time when i was still
studying in nus at that time as a pc
student
uh so that's the next slide where uh
with a group of friends we thought that
you know beyond the school works and
all the design hypothesis and all that
can we do something
really on the ground so that's how we
started this group called really
architecture react
and we started to organize workshop for
students
that really not just you know hiding the
studio coming out your own design but
going to the community
in doing interview working on the ground
doing all the free work and see how we
can actually
extrapolate all these new insights and
come up with new ideas
and in the end we actually presented
this to uh
the urban redevelopment authority i
think
we are just a bunch of young students at
that time but we
feel such a privilege to able to
actually put together
a series of this workshop last uh for a
couple of years
uh so it's called design my place back
in 2008
and that's kick-start the whole uh
notion of hey we actually want to
do more uh to involve the community as
part of the design process
uh that's actually how i stumble upon
participatory design as well so you look
at this example we did uh
planning uh this urban design uh
workshop on
in queenstown uh queensway uh
you know area so this building actually
is no longer there
uh but we are so glad that we actually
do some kind of documentation and some
kind of conversation
with the students at that time and that
quickly bring me to uh
about a few years later when i joined
sutd
as a faculty that's when um
we worked with uh participate design
uh at that time and also with shop house
and call
uh our initial kind of working together
at that time
uh shop housing called abby was a
festival director for archifest
whereas uh pid is working on uh
mcpherson
and i brought my students along and see
what can we do
to bring design into community spaces
and that's how we uh stumbled upon
the idea of parking day as well uh so
this idea of
turning uh parking lot into a park for a
day
and that's where we actually uh involved
the community
uh at that time uh back in 2013
and without you know uh some kind of
like
official approval uh we actually
appropriate some of this carpark space
and that started with the first parking
day in singapore
the idea is actually to help people to
move across safely because
a lot of uh people especially elderly
are crossing the road
to the other side of all the hawker
center uh every day and sometimes
accident did happen so you want to use
that as a signal
for cars to slow down and stay in time
to bring you know people although it's
actually legal to cross it's actually
not illegal here it's 50 or
50 meters away from the traffic junction
junction but we want to make it
safer and through this parking day
installation it helped us
to achieve that and that is actually one
of the idea that
we work with community to arrive in but
right after that we we never expected
that this
idea of parking they actually continue
to flourish
uh for the next uh couple of years until
uh even this year
uh so there are many years that we see
people starting to participate
in this we work very closely with ura
since then
uh and some of the movement actually uh
on its own like the play forward uh
movement
whereas uh some of our friends actually
put pianos
onto the spaces and invite people to
play piano at the public spaces
uh and and many other kind of new kind
of public space that was actually
innovated through this program that
happened every year
so uh in for colors we also took this
opportunity
to kickstart our own kind of public
space investigation so we partnered with
one of
our sponsors in overlay next slides that
we came up with
a series of parklet module
where the residents can bring down their
own pots of flood plans
and then uh put it at the public space
and police model and become
you know public furniture and they can
actually arrange it
uh in their own way to suit in different
kind of adapt in different kind of
so we thought that by initiating this
we can actually involve uh you know the
community to have a stronger sense of
ownership and taking care of the place
by themselves
so this was a initial experiment we
started with parking day
uh and since then uh we have been also
uh working on other kinds of
module uh as you can see in the next
slide so
we were invited by hdb to put out a to
re-imagine
uh white deck spaces in fact how it
started is we put some of
our modules either voider and then
people start to use it
and then we talk to hdb and say hey why
don't we design the void text faces
and with that very interestingly we
curated a series of
uh participatory process you can see on
the top right corner
we built the model avoid that we invite
the
residents to come and share with us how
they want to place the furniture
use the furniture in different ways and
and we work with our engineers
uh uh and just to reconceptualize this
place and design the lighting
uh such that it will change according to
how one you know replace the
layout of the furniture so the the the
camera would then detect
the configuration of furniture and then
switch on the
particular lighting that we have
pre-programmed in
and hopefully that will become a more
you know
smart kind of void that that's so it's
called smart voy deck
uh so interestingly we set up as an
experiment uh there are a couple of
things that we learned here
uh uh like the furniture because
it's so easily moved around uh it's
fabric
so some of the fabric was spoiling after
a while
uh and one of the batch was actually
stolen
so we couldn't find it back so that's
some of the lesson that we learned at
public space
is you know we have to have a lot more
consideration when we design
uh with the community so we brought in
the second round we invite the resident
back again hey
tell us what is the issues here how do
you see that we can improve the design
and all that so there's a lot of
uh feedback and also again we use models
as a way
to have interaction with the uh
residents
uh and they they really like the park
bench they told us
even the colors uh because it's easy to
maintain
and then it's uh comfortable it's cool
uh you know
as in physically cool to sit around so
we redesigned that kind of
park bench idea and turn it into a
different kind of uh
modules and therefore the resident can
actually reconfigure them again in
different way
but this time round is a lot more
heavier so you need about two persons to
carry
so they can't bring it home well in a
way that
helped to curate that new kind of space
as well
and uh i think the residents are still
using it until now
let's do that
right uh and with the voidtech
experiment uh and with the lighting
we also learned a lot that we can apply
to our other projects
uh we applied uh to i like marina to
not just looking at void deck spaces but
looking at you know
urban spaces and this time we uh
re uh use some of the uh recycled
umbrella
and and pipes and everyday material and
see how we can actually
create a new kind of public space in the
city
so this is part of the ili marina
exhibition uh it's a temporary public
space and we are so
honored to be selected as uh one of the
international artists featuring the work
uh so we bring in the idea of smart
lighting again using sensors that we can
detect
different kind of human flow then
different set of lighting can actually
be activated
uh to create different interests uh in
our city
uh against the backdrop marina they i
think
that's really a wonderful uh opportunity
for us
it's called dandelion because it looks
like the uh then the line
in a way we do we try we try
yeah but we all this experiment i think
it's very important that how we bring
back to a real physical space that can
actually bring
into the community so uh we were
partnering with ntuc health to
reconceive
a new kind of social space
for the residents who have just moved
into the studio apartment
so in singapore there is this new
typology
that's called studio apartment for those
who are above 55 you can
opt to relocate from where you stay
currently to uh do a new studio
apartment
uh so that in some other and in fact
most of the cases you can actually
monetize
some of your larger uh house units uh so
that when you move
to a studio apartment you can have some
spare cash
to help you with the retirement as well
and since you you also have
need to have smaller units that also
helped you to run
uh so but as everyone
coming together and live into a new
place it's very important
that we look into the community space to
support these
newcomers and we know that many of these
uh
social uh service spaces are catered
for the lower income uh people so in
this case
uh the kind of demographic is quite
different
uh they there are different kind of
seniors that you
expect there they have they have a lot
of expectation as well so we bring them
together again we actually got uh
a partner with nuc to knock on every
door and get them
down to uh participate in our workshop
at the voidtech space itself to ask them
what would you like to see in this space
and and through a series of exercises
that tell us how we can actually
reimagine some of the space
and in fact this is the outcome of their
own inputs
they want to have certain kind of
nostalgic relation
to what they have used and seen back in
the days
before we use rotten food cover
as the lighting and we
instead of closing up as the ceiling
we open up the entire ceiling to have
this kind of airy open
environment in fact this place is like a
tara fair
from the hdb uh house public housing
block
behind to the uh bus stop in front
so instead of closing off the area
exclusively only for
the selected residents to come in to
enjoy this air conditioned space we
actually uh uh suggest that why don't we
just leave the front and the back door
open
during the opening hours so that anybody
can pass by
and that also creates a sense of
community because
then any residents who pass by through
this tariff will then be able to
interact
with the senior resident who are saying
that rather than exclusive space
and and hopefully that will create a new
kind of community
environment as well and another
interesting thing is that
many of them feedback that they want to
do planting but in fact we don't have
space
uh to for them to do planting so we
actually told them why don't we turn
your your window into your community
garden so we actually designed these
pots
where they again bring down their own
pots or plants
and uh you know started to curate this
window space
and that become their community uh
garden wall
so this is also kind of innovation that
it only came out
because we had interaction with the
community
and apart from uh ntuc health seniors
uh we were uh also very uh privileged to
work with ada
examiners this is a station uh where we
uh they help out with
people with dementia uh so this block is
in uh it's particularly interesting
because my uncle actually stayed
right above and he feedback to me that
he stayed there for
so many years he didn't know what's
happening inside the wall
so after we uh interact with the center
managers as well as the
uh uh uh people with the manager who are
visiting the place
uh and you know it's different kind of
participation technique that's needed
later i can share with you a bit more uh
that
we the first thing that we realized we
need to do
is to break down the wall so literally
this is going to break down all the
fiscal war and then uh replace them with
uh
the last fenestration but still we want
to provide that privacy
uh so we co-create this uh
art feature wall together with the
people with dementia where they can
actually showcase
their artwork so this becomes not just a
war anymore it's
actually a uh art world and not just an
art war
what happened is when it was built the
uh it was during the chinese new year
period
uh the neighbors who are from upstairs
coming down and started to donate the
chinese new year decoration uh made of
ang tao
the red packets and all that so this
will become
a curation uh you know between the
neighbors the community together
with the people of uh dementia so they
become a community project that change
all the time uh so so that gives us
really a wonderful feeling where we
can really see how design can play such
a role
in community and bring community
together
and that itself i think is also
true the kind of participatory process
that we learn
throughout these projects let's come to
our recent project
that we bring all this uh learning that
we had
before uh and worked with uh touched
community services
uh uh i am killed in this case
uh and the participatory process i think
this for this one is probably the most
extensive one we took about a year
uh and went through four uh i think four
exercises a series of exercise
from from without having a site without
having a program
uh to you know identify what kind of
program that the residents are looking
for
which side that is most convenient for
most of the
residents and how the
design can actually contribute not just
for those who
uh you know uh seniors but also for the
residents
who are staying in the block for example
uh the
the idea of turning the uh the
shelter walkway as well as the drop-off
area into a public space it's actually
through a lot of consultation
uh with the residents that we realize
that you know less than like to hang
around at the drop-off area while they
are waiting for their school bus
or they're waiting for their grad car
and then that's where people interact
so we turn it into spaces where people
can sit around
and hang out and that's just next to
the community garden next door so they
can appear that what people are doing
in fact the community garden was
actually transformed from a series of
parking lots
uh so this is also some of the very
interesting idea that after we work with
the residents we also work very closely
with the grassroots
to seek their advice and see whether can
we convert some of the carpark into a
real part in this case
we really bring the idea of parking day
into real life permanently
and then and we are very happy to have
the support from
all the uh classroom leaders as well as
the residents
and of course authority to able to make
this project realize so there's a lot of
new idea that we're trying to break
through
uh social service center as a public
space and not just under the void
but break away from that you know
transparent box
into the public spaces around the block
and turn into outdoor
indoor spaces all leave into one so this
become a new typologies
that we are trying to propose that the
authority may be able to look into
in future some of the other projects
in fact we have done many other projects
uh but they were not realized
i think many of the practices will share
the same kind of experience with us
uh many of those proposed uh was wasn't
being carried out due to many other
reasons as well
uh but we just want to take this chance
to share with you
uh there are a lot more idea that we
want to see in this case like for
example is to
transform uh originally this is a bus
depot
into uh social spaces uh for the
seniors as well and how to open up the
space
uh as part of the integrated community
spaces
uh for both young and old and with all
this
hypothetical kind of experiment thought
experiment we are also really really
happy
to be able to partner with lynn
foundation
to put together all this idea that we
had
accumulated over the years that actually
uh you know a lot of those ideas came
out from
our interaction with the community to
come up with these 10
typologies of future senior living what
we call second beginnings
so it is a book that we uh published uh
in 2018
you can download the book for free uh
all the ideas there for free as well you
can just copy them
feel free to just copy there's no
copyright except that you
you know the book is copyright but the
idea is not
so there are there are many ideas that
we came up with uh i
like to encourage you to take a look at
that and transforming the underused
spaces
like for example under the uh viaduct uh
some of the leftover
uh factory or hangar spaces
some of the old schools how can we
reappropriate them
into all different kind of typologies
for future senior living
in fact that's in preparation for myself
i mean one day i would like to leave
one of them too and there are many
different kind of aspirations and needs
uh
by diverse group of people uh so we
would like to
uh you know push for the agenda that you
know
senior living is just not just one type
or one stereotype
of kind of people but we are all diverse
so we should provide the kind of
diversity
uh and that only came true if you are
able to listen
uh to people uh to understand the needs
and all these uh ideas actually came
from
this series of workshop that we have uh
uh
you know participate or organized uh in
the past seven years
uh so you can see it's not just one
project but
every project we have a very extensive
uh
process of how we can actually involve
the
the community as part of the co-design
process
uh one particular one to uh uh highlight
is
you know the jigsaw puzzle that you see
uh one of the picture
uh this is one of the two that we
developed for people with dementia
because it's very hard you know for us
to
communicate uh in in the normal way so
we use
jigsaw puzzles as part of their you know
daily
uh you know tools that they use to play
with and then we get them
to just talk about why they choose a
different
kind of puzzle how they put together the
puzzle and through that we try to
understand and learn their internal
thinking
okay i got two minutes left so i will
just share
with you the rest of the thing that
we're doing one other thing is that
because of the uh lockdown we know that
i mean
but uh uh it's uh when we uh you know
not able to go out
as often uh we were then experimenting
with
uh online tools so next we came up with
this
uh apps called new kampung uh it's
already
available online in the app store or
google play you can download it
play with it uh basically is to
encourage
uh residents living in the same
neighborhood or community
to start to you know do things together
so you want to show how you
you know do healthy cooking you can
organize
online zoom and or you can find uh
different what we call
khaki uh cocky group to come together
and and
you know uh learn from each other and
hopefully this
kind of online tools can then transit
into
uh offline real life uh interest group
uh
in the near future uh just one to uh
okay i think there is one sketch that
i've done later i think
yeah stella will share with you uh how
oh yeah this one right uh i'll just go
through quickly
uh check as an exercise that we were
asked to do so
i you know asked to do a bad diagram and
quickly pull up my academic mind
so i'm sorry that it sounds a bit uh
technical uh for now but what i want to
show is that
uh to link uh community environment and
design together
i i like to highlight these few uh
keywords as well
core creation between the community and
design
core learn between our natural
environment and design
and connect between our community and
environment and from there we can start
to see
a series kind of processes and framework
that other
designers are using across the world as
well um
like uh how to co-create we talk about
design empowerment
how do we learn from our environment we
talk about radical indigenism
a term that was coined by julia watson
lately
uh connect how do we connect we need to
be more impacted in our intervention
so let me share with you some of the uh
case that we come across
uh around the world uh you can see uh
anna herringer
uh you know working in bangladesh how
they use
local material mark and bamboo create
new kinds of
schools uh for the children and adult
existing and try to
use the local language and natural
language and create different kind of
public space
voltron i'm sure you heard of how he's
expert in doing
bamboo prasun kumar uh working in
india to trying to eradicate
homelessness in this world
we look at how different designers work
with community around the world uh
kalkin's studio will be
you know resident in vichy island and
create different kind of public
space for them sinjin from taiwan
working with uh community in the
aboriginal
hill tribe and see how we learn from
them he literally
lived there and worked there together
with the
the people uh shark that's from
indonesia our own
uh symbolic architect triyon king uh
bringing
two 20 uh 20 architects went to cambodia
and actually worked with the cambodian
community to design different kind of
infrastructure many others group like
mass design group
people architecture office wta from
philippines
sa architects they're all you know very
empathetic
about the urban environment and how
small architecture
no matter what scale it is can actually
you know intervene
and create the kind of connection
between community
and space and places and and we do some
of this i think we are very very
happy to be able to invite all these
architects and designers
to come and join us next week uh
in fact i would like to take this chance
to do a shout out to
uh my my team in uh akifest
singapore archives which will happen
tomorrow it's starting tomorrow there's
a whole
five weeks festival uh theme
architecture saving our world
i would like to invite you to join us to
be able to
learn and also share and exchange ideas
throughout the exciting
you know festival to really look at how
participatory design can be a force for
good and is part of the creative
activism thank you thank you king hua
wow that was indeed uh uh
really opened our eyes right indeed i
know it's a challenge to keep to the
time
but thank you thank you for giving some
time sorry i love
it's all right i love your your your
team for this year and i definitely
can't wait you know to to to participate
uh in some of these programs in
artifacts
very very appropriate team i think you
know what we're going through now and
a lot of examples that you share also
talk about you know working with
different communities from the young
like your students to you know the
elderly
and you know sometimes people just
assume that design needs to be this
you know very like smooth and wonderful
and
nice to look at but then you know what
we know like
in a lot of our work that it is really
just having a good idea
and learning from what the community
needs not
what the designer wants right so um i
think uh thank you so much we'll come
back and explore some of
the topics and the discussion later on
in the q a
next up we have with us uh mr larry
larry um is the executive director of
participative design
and uh participate in design is a
non-profit design organization
a very close friend to us at chapels
and co and they help neighborhoods and
public institutions
design community owned spaces and
solutions
and larry started his career in
architecture practice
and interestingly he has moved into this
field and he now sees himself
as a designer and community organizer in
his work
so larry please um take it away
thank you so much stella and very
inspirationally talking huh
so uh yeah hi everybody uh my name is
larry i'm from participating in design
so um we have a design organization that
really focus a lot on you know
designing with people and not just for
people
and that i mean this is actually a great
summary of what we do
but when we talk about designing you
know with people
what do we really mean by that right so
a little bit about myself
as what stella have said you know i i
started off
you know learning architecture but back
in school i always questioned
myself you know as an architecture
student why are we often just taught
how building should look like you know
how aesthetic
it should look like right but um we
never really talk about the community
or even getting ideas of how we should
co-create with them
so i think that was when i really
realized that you know
architecture and design could play a
bigger role in making our society
or community a better place to live in
so that was when i decided to kind of
like
sway away a little bit from the
architecture scene and really exploring
how can we introduce participatory
design
in the build environment and in this
four to five years that i've been doing
participatory design
what i found out is that participatory
design
could be a powerful tool um for citizen
participation and really building that
sense of home
right and but how do we actually do it
so if you look at participation these
days right i think these things come to
your mind
right when you talk about you know
citizen engagement you have
you know the minister standing in front
and talking about design concepts you
know
oh we have a focus group like what you
see on the screen
or you know focus group that is like a
little bit more informal with daily
citizens
but if i were to ask you this question
if a 60 year old grandma you asked them
to attend
any of all these things how do you think
she will feel
you know sometimes it can be a bit scary
for her so the question we ask ourselves
and participate in design is then
how can we break down very complicated
design concepts
and very intimidating you know
participation platform into something
that you know daily people can relate to
and allow them to then share with us the
ideas of how they can make the
environment better
so for today i'll be sharing three
little case studies all right
of the project that we do in pid and
hopefully that will kind of inspire you
guys to think about
how participatory design can be
introduced in your respective
neighborhoods
now if you look at the first image over
here this is a neighborhood in telugu
and just like what qinghua have shared
earlier you know in singapore we have a
lot of all this
what we call void deck spaces they may
seem empty
but if you look at the next slide they
are actually filled with life
so in this case uh in this community
that we work with
we wanted to do something in the void
deck but we are really not sure what
we should do there and we feel that
participatory design you know could be
introduced to this community
to brainstorm together with these
seniors here you know what can we do you
know we have a sum of money here but
what can we do to make it work for your
community
so we didn't want to come in with a
persistent idea but rather we want to
co-create solutions with them
so how do we do it right so we really
make friends with the seniors first and
we realize food is indeed life as you
can see in the image earlier there's a
lot of soup right
we realized that seniors in this
community you know cook the soup
and distribute uh weekly in this uh soup
eating exercise you know that they have
but if you think about it you know where
does this suit come from
we actually realize from our engagement
and talking with the seniors that you
know
you look at this image over here they
literally this 60
70 year old senior volunteer will be
using this trolley you see
over here with they will kind of tie the
ropes around it and they were trolling
two blocks away from the central kitchen
into this void deck space to distribute
the suit to the seniors
and that is actually a very tiring
process and very dangerous because
they often have to worry whether the
soup will actually topple over
along the way so that they'll be very
extra careful
so uh we realized this is actually one
of the problems that the seniors would
like to tackle
right and we also started talking to
seniors around the neighborhood um
you know what are some opportunities or
things that you know they would like to
see in this void deck space and if you
look at the next slide
uh what we found out was that a lot of
these seniors here other than exercising
here
a lot of them have stayed in the
neighborhood you know for 30
40 years so they were younger when they
were staying in this neighborhood but
now they have grown
older they no longer are able to visit
the spaces around their neighborhood as
they you as they wish they could have
um you know many years ago when they
were younger and more mobile
so you know together with our artists
volunteers as well as the seniors
we decided to actually transform this
space where they do exercise
to kind of bring those spaces that they
use to hang out when they're younger
around the neighborhood
and translate them into painting in this
white deck space
right and this became one of the design
intervention
and if you look at the next slide other
than this uh we also had a very
extensive you know um
copy talk session and design clinics
with the seniors
to actually co-design what you call this
the soup trolley
right so in the past they just have a
you know impromptu trolley
but here we really want to do something
meaningful and
this whole trolley was designed to the
detail of you know where the flat should
be
how tall this thing should be how the
handle should be held
and i think all these ideas came from
the seniors themselves
now if you look at this whole process
you know this is actually what we call
participatory design
because we create solutions with the
residents
and to the detail of whatever product it
is
so a question i always get is that you
know does participatory design need to
start big
it need not start big it can start small
like in this case
even to a simple trolley right we can
really get the seniors empowered and
from this whole process what we also
found out was that seniors actually felt
a lot more
you know invested in the community
because now they know that you know they
still have what it takes to contribute
back
to the you know to the community and to
the neighborhood and this is actually
very good for their well-being as
seniors
and i think this is the kind of value
that participatory design can bring
about
if only they were given a chance to
contribute right
so this is one example and another
example
i think um it's a community kitchen
project that we did
quite recently at fajr spring
neighborhood now
uh we actually did many community
kitchens before and most of the time the
seniors are very enthusiastic about it
but in this particular neighborhood it
is very unique because
when we went to the community the
seniors actually told us like
no i don't want a community kitchen go
away you know i don't want
i don't want a kitchen in my in in this
center
and it started to struck us like oh well
this is really a very different
challenge because in the past we always
have very enthusiastic seniors but now
we are seniors who are not really open
to the idea of teaching
so how can we go about doing it do we
even need to build a kitchen or even
shall we even design a kitchen right so
we actually started off by just um
uh understanding the community right we
actually have this community notice
board and
um next slide uh we also did a series of
copy talk sessions
with the seniors and we actually then
found out what was the problem
the problem is that it's not that they
do not want the kitchen
but they were very worried because the
center is very small
you know they're very worried that like
you know if we build a kitchen there it
will take away something very important
to them
and guess what it is their bingo's face
because these seniors play bingo almost
every week
so you know to them bingo is live so
we then after that decided to pose a
question to them to get excited like you
know what
there are also some seniors who really
love cooking we found out
so we then decided to have a design
workshop with them right if you look at
the next slide
um and we actually asked the seniors you
know okay you know what
why not we try to design the kitchen
together such that we can have a bingo
space and yet at the same time
we can cook together with your community
and at the same time we can also prepare
meals before your outings in this center
and that idea then got the seniors very
excited
you know and then with the model and of
course with our facilitators who speak
many different languages
we then decided to have this workshop
with the seniors and
look at the seniors they're really very
happy and at first the seniors were not
interested in the whole idea of a
kitchen
but just a tweaking of perspective they
started coming together and
brainstorming many many different ideas
so this is the end product of how the
kitchen then looked like
and these are all designed by seniors
and the ideas all came from them
so if you look at the next slide um you
know it's a really
interesting kitchen because there's
mobile components right there's nature
in it there's a photo wall
so what we did over here as designers is
really to help conceptualize these ideas
for the seniors
so that they can actually you know be
part of this whole process
of designing this whole community space
and
if you look at what programs they've
been doing right now i mean
you know seniors right efforts they told
us they're not interested in cooking
they won't cook
but look at the left you see all these
very interesting magics and you know
seniors started you know being part of
the process they started coming down for
the programs
they started being interested in the
space and i remember very clearly during
the launch of the project
one of the aunties actually came to me
and said like you know
i really want to thank you for you know
designing this kitchen because this is
not something that i thought would even
be possible
i never thought our center could look
like that and that to me was the
greatest takeaway because
by just listening to the community and
giving them a voice
it may be a very simple thing to do but
it really really means a lot to the
community
and the whole sense of home and
ownership will then be strengthened
and this is actually a very good example
of uh how we use participatory design
to give you know the community a voice
and ownership
and building that sense of home within
the community
and um of course in this last example
i'm going to share with you today
um it's a bigger scale township planning
program that we have done so in
singapore we have this thing called the
neighborhood renewal program
whereby um you know the government will
give you a sum of money and
you know in the past how the town
councils are doing is that you know they
would just mail out survey forms for
everybody
and you just fill up the survey form and
that's it you know uh
and they collaborate the survey form you
want to see this business and i just
delivered that to you right
but i think in this case um the
minister of the the member of parliament
in this area wanted to do something a
bit different
so um they were actually asking pid if
we can come into this neighborhood
to you know engage the residents of
something more interestingly
rather than you know survey forms so if
you look at this neighborhood you know
they have very beautiful
eucalyptus tree which is very unique um
in singapore
right so what we started off was we just
started you know walking around the
neighborhood with the residents right
even though the next slide
uh we have this thing called the walking
conversations whereby we engage the
residents and walk with them
and we also got the architect to
actually attend this with us so
if you look at the center uh that is our
miss our architect mr chua
right uh and i think he actually um
walked together with us
to listen to the residents needs as well
before we come up with solutions
right and i think in this case um
residents actually felt very empowered
because
they don't really get an architect all
the time you know to really walk with
you to listen to your concerns
and we also have like we look at the
next slide um we also did what we call
neighborhood pop-ups because we do not
want to wait for people to come to us
we want to go to where the people are so
um here
in pid we really went out there with our
volunteers
to actively talk to residents so you
know people who use the park
or people who um you know just walk by
the area
they are able to contribute their views
and their ideas
for the neighborhood as well and for us
to have a better sensing of how the park
you know and what is working well and
what is not working well in the
neighborhood
and of course for people who have more
time to spare
even look at the next slide we also
actually do
wide skill neighborhood engagement
through model as well
so something that is more interesting
for people and kids to contribute their
ideas
so you know imagine a survey form and a
platform like this
i think we really want to explore the
notion of making engagement fun
so that you know be a 12 year old kid or
60 year old grandma
your v will be captured in all these
engagement activities
so uh lastly i think we also do design
workshops to engage residents
uh you know of different ages who really
want to give a little bit more in-depth
you know
solution and in-depth ideas we have this
opportunity for them as well
and you know something very interesting
during this workshop is that you know
they got really excited
and we even give them a participatory
budgeting activity whereby they are
empowered to you know even allocate
funds
to all these different activities that
you know or different facilities
that they would like to introduce in
their neighborhood and
um this in the whole process i think
what we actually found out is that you
know residents
really find it very interesting that
they're able to you know even
go down to the detail of deciding how
much money they would like to allocate
for what facilities
and it's definitely very very different
way of planning our neighborhoods as
opposed to you know how
a traditional engagement method like
survey forms would actually work
and um the last slide uh is that i think
what we managed to actually do is really
that we found out
one very interesting finding that uh we
found out was that you know all these
eucalyptus trees were very very unique
to the neighborhood
and something that is of a lot of
memories for the residents to stay
around this area near limbaugh park
so the end outcome was that we managed
to preserve these trees and manage to
work with the architect
to actually revise his design to not
clear all these trees
but actually work around these streets
to preserve their social memory and
social fabric
within the neighborhood so in this
example i think
one thing that participatory
participation design value added to this
whole process
was really you know how can we preserve
social memories in a fast-changing
society like singapore
i think participation design in this
case allowed that opportunity
you know for residents to voice out
their concerns and their memories
and then be able to work with the
architect to design a more meaningful
design outcome
so just to summarize my sharing i think
uh in pid and in the work that we do
we do feel that every individual you
know be it a 60o grammar or
you know or whether you are a 12 year
old kid or not
you really have something positive to
contribute to the design process
and i think as designers we should
really sometimes put away our designer
ego
and really start by listening to the
community and you will really be
surprised
by you know how much knowledge you know
the locals can actually provide you with
and i hope with this we could see our
public you know as collaborators and not
just consumers
and we can embrace more participatory
design in singapore and
i think with this i will just end off my
sharing here and of course if you have
more questions
i'll be more than happy to answer them
during the q a so
yes uh back to you stella yeah thank you
so much
thank you larry wow you know i learned
something new i never realized we have
eucalyptus tree
here in singapore so
um anyway thank you for that i think you
have touched on
quite a few critical points you know
about how everyone can be collaborators
you know not necessarily just artists or
designers or creatives
per se but there's a lot of inputs you
know um
from uh the people because they're using
the place
every day and um on your point as well
about
social memory i think this ability
for the community to take ownership and
to feel empowered
um is something that is not necessarily
um the initiative is not necessarily
like something that
us the biggest singaporeans will
naturally display
all right so we'll discuss a few of
those thoughts later on
uh now up uh to our final speaker for
today our final panelist
ms kamiya ramachandran is the founder of
be fantastic
attack art initiative kamiya will be
sharing her
international experiences working with
community and designing
in india san francisco and london
she is very passionate about engaging
communities for a better design world
and today she'll be sharing with us her
presentation co-design
for place making kamiya over to you
thank you stella for that kind
introduction and
a big thank you to the organizers today
for really
creating the space to hold such a
relevant discussion so i'd like to
present to you today
experiences over the last two decades of
my practice
experiences across three continents
america uk
india and now singapore where i'm trying
to make my home
it's really exciting to see the speakers
before me hua and
larry to see your work and really know
that there is a world here that does
this kind of stuff that i
am absolutely passionate about so i
present this to you as a series of
stories
or anecdotes of my learning and my
experiences
across the board i'd like to start off
with this idea
of the column effect column is a tamil
word for this daily ritual practice
of stepping outside your private domain
and almost creatively embracing the
public space around you
in a marking ritual so the lady of the
house goes out
splashes water on her front yard cleans
it up
and marks it in these extremely
intricate
geometrical patterns with really hard
mathematical calculations that generate
it
and uh the the act of making this column
for me
represents a lot of what participatory
design does which brings you out of the
comfort of your home
into public space and attribute it with
the same
love and care that you would give your
home and so that's kind of something i
would like to
reiterate through the works that i do
the first um
project i'd like to share with you is
called look at us in bangalore in india
for this we went to a really low income
community in the city
near the also dhobi ghat much like the
kobe guard
station i guess you have here and the
community center all broken up
was a space where teenage boys would be
smoking
a space of blight and with the children
in the community we really worked
workshopped them
to understand their aspirations and with
a splash of color
and co-creation what was a really
scary space to walk into became the
space where the little girls in the
community were saying
maybe we can do our dance lessons here
so
um democratizing this creative power
allowing children when told never to
scroll on their walls
to engage in a process and actually
scroll on the walls and do something
meaningful
was really great but the profound thing
here was
my child is in the image on the right i
took him along
to paint with me and have fun with me
and the subliminal learning
of an understanding of people from a
diverse background from his
speaking very different languages that
he didn't understand
but once they all had the paintbrush in
their hand
and they were you know having fun by the
end of our six-hour session from the
morning to the evening
he had broken into the community and i
was amazed to see that
so we went on in this organization that
i was the director of in bangalore for
the last six years
we did a lot of public art and public
space design
through it um we did we developed a
program
that did this we went to schools from
different socioeconomic and cultural
backgrounds and said can we bring you
together
using creative mediums to engage
so here we have international schools
working with the local government school
we brought the children together they
drew together they played together they
they problem-solved together and in this
case
the students articulated that their
stairway was the most boring space in
the class in the school
and so we muralled
and had a butterfly garden that the
students designed
and constructed with their own bare
hands
the big learning here was creative
practice really
brings diverse people to
have fun together and therefore learn
from each other
and instilling civic pride and ownership
in commons
at a very young age is a powerful
starting place
this then we extended ourselves to
in this case and here we have the
singapore
international foundation that runs this
fabulous workshop
called the arts forward fellowship and
uh so here we have close to 100 students
that we workshopped in
a school government school in chennai
with 32
international artists again communities
from very diverse backgrounds
but here we made poetry together we the
children of the government school
illustrated with tangrams the poems
and then painted it up on their wall
with the international artists
and it was another again reconfirming
the profundity of this kind of creative
practice
that can bring communities together and
kind of build a bond between them
and from urban low-income
india i take you to noe valley
in san francisco here we worked with
the business improvement district who
had mandated us to do a streetscape plan
for the 24th street which is their high
street or their
commercial business uh street they
wanted to understand how to have
people come out onto the street and
really enjoy the street a lot more
of course it was good for business but
the focus was
close to a six month long highly
interactive community engaged process
and um the the big learnings here
were that with participatory design the
execution of the project
the pressure that the community put to
make it happen was phenomenal it just
happened in no time
and moulding the building built
environment place making is a capital
intensive
exercise and so you have to get it right
the first time
sit me as an architect sitting in the
confines of my office
i designed something but the minute i
took it back to the community
um they were like oh no no no don't do
this don't put this bench here because
the coldest san francisco winds blow
down the street
let's turn it around this corner where
the warm sun comes down
so it's local wisdom and this kind of
local wisdom is a make or break of
neighborhood design if you may right so
that
is a big learning from that project we
went on to the better streets plan
the san francisco planning department
was really proactive
they engaged us to understand what the
problems in san francisco streets were
so we engaged about 20 different
communities all across the city to
to get this information much like larry
said
community engagement is not a boring
exercise
it can be as fun as it can be as
engaging as
a designer would like to make it
so in this case of course lots of visual
exercises
street walks and even a shopping
exercise we gave all
the members close to 50 people in this
community meeting
money for them to go around and shop and
the image in the bottom left
shows you that it's actually a method of
voting
polling but really visual exciting
close to real life kind of method so
just like you shop for furniture in your
home
you shop the furniture in the street and
designers are called upon to be a lot
more than what
school teaches us to be we are
facilitators we're event planners
we are mediators because when you have a
table of diverse
opinions being flung in we need to know
how to mediate
and collect and receive and hold the
space really well
and from noe valley in san francisco we
go to gujarat
in india and this is in 2001.
there was an earthquake in this area
and i spent close to 16 months in a
village
helping them rebuild their homes
it was a turning point in my life my
first project out of architecture
college and
we had a whole bunch of workshops with
the community using models working with
children working with
just the adults the women separately
from the men
and the picture in the bottom right that
you see
is working with homeowners who are
actually home builders
it's as basic they build their own homes
and to
explain to them how earthquake safety
can manifest in their cultural typology
and for the first time i understood here
the difference between
beneficiaries and co-creators much like
larry's experience of how can they how
can public be collaborators and not just
consumers
in this case beneficiaries because next
libraries
um i understood this difference
i was a student who was not i was a
fresh architecture graduate
who was not sure how to put this in my
portfolio
because the design the design of the uh
the
the touch of the designer was very
minimal you couldn't see it and so the
glossy magazines couldn't really take
this
as easily but very quickly i had i
realized i needed to redefine
my parameters of success and when i took
a group of japanese funders to
other locations and other rehabilitation
projects
i realized the value of what we had done
with participatory design
so the image you see on the top left top
right
is how rehabilitation happened in most
villages around me
it was cookie cutter style cad drawings
that had just emerged from the ground
little concrete boxes that were
climatically and
culturally absolutely inappropriate for
that community
on the left is a map that we paced and
measured drew
off the village that i lived in
and it's this organic part-like thing
with connections and communities
and a central space that people gathered
in and
with the temple at a grocery store and
here you had rows and columns that they
just didn't know what to do with
on the picture in the bottom right which
is the village that i built
you had a kitchen the little window that
you see is the kitchen window people
cooked with twigs and tree bark
and it suited up the kitchen so they
would never have a kitchen inside the
house and all those cookie cutter
modules
had kitchens inside the house with
platforms where they stood
while the villagers only know how to sit
while they cook
so just basic things like this showed me
how
a participatory process had embraced
their cultural type
and made them very very happy
collaborators
and from there we go to uk i had a shop
stint in london
where i was a built environment expert
part of a network of about 400
professionals
that the design council in london hired
out into this directory just to say that
public space making is a very complex
endeavor and so
architects landscape architects urban
designers planners
graphic designers sociologists
community designers had to all kind of
be in this network
that they could pull depending on the
project and what it demanded
and from there we go back to urban india
bangalore
uh jaga is where is the organization
that i was director of
and bangalore with its rapid
urbanization we had a whole
host of elevated roadways while
the traffic problems were mildly sorted
with
those roadways the spaces below
neighborhoods below were just cut
through
like a knife and the top images
show you how we had not
thought through what happens to spaces
below flyovers as we call them
so this is project ufo under flyovers
they had posters in them they had
garbage thrown around them
urination and real spaces
of negativity within the city so
some one of this is the second project
the image is in the bottom
where um all we did
in terms of community engagement was we
stopped
close to 40 people who were walking
across the space and said
could we have five minutes of your time
we just need you to drop off your shadow
it was a really weird ask
but we asked them to do it and there was
a 10-minute conversation as to why we're
doing this
but all they did was gave us their
shadow to a theme
and the artist then went on to it
um the the point i'd like to make with
this is
just five minutes of investment of the
community's time
two weeks later we had posters that came
back onto these artists art
art pieces the artists were really upset
and uh we were scrambling to say okay
now we need to go and clean it up and
before we could even organize ourselves
one of the people who had dropped his
shadow off was
a faculty in a nearby college he took 20
of his students and cleaned the entire
thing up and gave us a call
and so the big learning here was even
light engagements go a long way in terms
of civic ownership
community making and the kind of
responsibility that it
incites and from this i wear another hat
where i'm a
i taught in a design college in india in
bangalore
and i am really invested in bringing
students along to get them excited about
public space design
in a participatory way it's a different
skill set
it's not just design it's more than
design
and so from the success of the first
ufo project we got five other ufo
projects
this being one of it next and in this
case we had students from
sao paulo and brazil germany and in
india architecture students who came
together
they designed they drew they uh
took the the designs back to the
community got feedback from them
and they actually built with their own
hands architectural students who did
master plans had never built a wall by
themselves
and so here we have uh students building
building things with their own hands and
kind of offering it to the community but
the community responding with equal
fervor so this community
in particular went about and raised
funds
to build a fence around the space that
we had made for them
double-edged sword i'm not sure i'm
convinced about fencing
but nevertheless for them it was this is
the only jewel among this
negative space and we need to keep it
safe and from this we got further
projects where we did a whole bunch more
within the same space
and really i was so excited that
from us being one organization with five
people
we were now 30 students and 20 students
going in
to really make a difference and so i
conclude
by saying community engagement
participatory design
co-designing with people in any shade
is integral for successful place making
and really that we have urban designers
we have architects
but we need place makers to sit in the
middle of that
and public public art and public space
design
really works nicely to bridge that gap
where we give nuanced design thinking
to common areas just around us
so thank you thank you come here
thank you can i have uh the rest of the
panelists to join
me yeah thank you all of you for sharing
very opening the process and insights of
your work
we have had quite a few questions coming
in thank you for those of you who have
been uh
setting notes of appreciation as well as
asking quite a few interesting questions
uh
those of you have just joined us we are
here halfway through we just finished
the presentation
um by three of our panelists and we are
going to
begin our q a very shortly yeah
so i i really you know from all three of
you
um who have shared there's just so many
similar tracks that come
through right this idea of ownership
as well as collaboration um i
i wanted to just have a chat very
quickly with all
three of you how do you embark
on your process like
um you know all of your training
architecture one of the questions as
well you know if i'm not training
architecture can
i begin and about this process so
i would like um um all three of you take
some time to just
talk a little bit about your process
like we have seen some very
interesting projects um that you have
shared about
the end product but we all we know that
often in our work as place makers
the success of the end product might not
necessarily translate to
that true understanding of the process
behind it and it's a lot of
hands-on work a lot of sweat a lot of
talking you know we have to
hit the ground talking and then our skin
must be very thick
you know we're going to be very texting
because we face a lot of rejection yeah
yeah i can see smiles so i think there
is a
agreement in that but yeah maybe we can
share with us a little bit in each of
your practice
which came first do you start off with
having already an idea or do you
actually go straight out i mean we know
that we do go out and talk to the
community and involve them
but often and there will be of course
funding and it causes a whole series of
challenges
but let's just very quickly if each of
you can talk about
how your work process has been how do
you begin
and what design tools or methodology do
you embark on
i think uh in pid any sharing i get this
question a lot you know like do we need
to have design skills to do it
to be honest for me i've just feel that
for participation designed to work
i think everybody is a designer you know
even if you're a chef
the way you're cooking that is a form of
design right i mean how you design the
dish how much ingredients you put in
so you know i think design is for
everyone it's not just for designers
and number one what should we do in
participatory design you know what is
the starting point
i always say number one is to connect
with your community and your audience
because all you need to do is to just
say hello
you know i think eight years and ten
years ago uh when you know my co-founder
misa
and her and her or the other co-founder
jen they just went down to the mcpherson
community and
you know just take balloons and uh
trolley and some bananas and
and apples and they say hey hello you
know i just want to get to know the
community a little bit better
can you spend five minutes to tell me
more about your community right
and for myself when i first went down to
jalan koko for my master thesis
i literally just went down and just
started making friends right saying
hello to the shop owners
saying hello to the auntie and and just
start talking
so i would say step one of course is to
start talking and understanding put that
designer ego aside
and start making friends and building
connections i think that is for me the
first step
and naturally once you have the first
step set up
you know things flow you know and and
things will start to come into play
uh how you want to design the process
you know what you should do to engage
the you know
um the auntie across the street or the
12 year old kid
who always hang on the basketball courts
you know things and ideas will come
naturally to
you and if you look at organizations
like my community you know
i don't think they are design trained in
that sense but they do a lot of great
you know
designing trails for the neighborhood
finding the heritage experience for the
neighborhood
i think all this don't really require
architecture knowledge you know so
i would say that we have the designer in
us it's just waiting for us to ignite it
through the process
of talking to people yeah but i'm not
sure how kamiya and kinkoi
uh you know agree with me or not but
yeah i'm interested to actually hear
from them as well
you know so i was just saying from my
point of view uh especially in the last
few years it's been very entrepreneurial
where we had this space and we had to
think up of what do we do with it
so and where to get the money from as
well
but what i will say is i think
as the organization itself we decided
that this is a key theme in
however we do these projects this is a
key theme that needs to run through
our work so we get the project but the
first thought is okay how do we involve
the public
at which points do we involve the public
and how do we ready the artists and the
designers to engage with the public
because that's also
a skill to be learned right so for us
it's it's the bottom line and
whatever project we try to bring in we
try to make sure that that bottom line
stays
go ahead kangaroo all right sorry
uh well i we actually had uh
interns uh from different disciplines as
well
you know she's a fantastic help for us
uh because she looked at it from a very
different angle and she really bring
a fresh perspective for us so so i
totally agree with larry
and kamiya i think uh dude we do have a
call team but we do
want to have this kind of multiple
perspective that will actually
enrich our understanding uh with the
community
and we do have a set of like a process
uh rather structured in a way
that we work very closely first with the
stakeholder
uh do identifying the problem uh i would
say
it's not a problem it's more like a i
don't really find a set of framework
that we want to start investigating i
think that's important
to really understand the stakeholder
that we are working with for example
recently we work with moht
uh so we really want to understand where
they're coming from looking at public
health
uh what is the intersection with
environment
and where are the entry point points we
look at and how do we identify
the behavior change that we want to see
from the public right once you identify
all these different
uh you know aspect that you would then
able to
chart out the process then we go to the
actual engagement
so there is a lot of pre-engagement work
that needs to be done that
most people didn't know that so when
i i think larry and kendall probably
agree with me
in a way that uh when we were always
asked to provide like you know
fee proposal this is the part that
people are like can you just take out
that one
say no we can't take it we need to
investigate first
before we actually do the engagement
right or you can use this video can you
do engagement tomorrow
no it can't right so that's the thing
that we really need to study
and and really understand the
stakeholder and then we come up with the
unique methods
for each of the projects in fact every
project we come up with new methods
to study to work with the the the
residents
and uh and some of this required just
one step some of you
require three step for the touch project
process
project we it took us four
four four subsequent session each
session we have date uh
different weekday week night uh weekday
night and a weekend day and we need to
see how to find the timing so all these
require a lot of logistical
planning as well uh so both methods and
logistics then
finally the co-creation process when
when we have the design and all that we
also need to
feedback into the community and how to
use that as a way to revise the
design and not just one time maybe
through different iteration
so that also require different technique
ultimately
after the project is built i think some
of the question was directed at that
how do you measure the success of the
project right so we also had to build in
the evaluation
process to see how we can get the
particip the users themselves
to come in to evaluate how happy they
are
or whether they can sustain the place
you know for long term
and all these take a lot of time for
investigation and
and you know development yeah
but you can see this is not just design
this is really beyond design this in
fact we are all learning at the same
time
so we really require a scientific mind a
technological
mind a humanistic mind uh
all come together to make this work yeah
thank you king well i think you sum it
up really well you know often
you know even in us i'll work at shaw
house and co at the same time i
i i get this ass you know say oh could
you bring that community you have
and just like bring them over you know
and i was like
i am not a religious leader or a cop
leader you know where i just come like
follow me and just come right
and and i think fundamentally as well we
always talk about
needing to be authentic needing to be
organic as well and
and unfortunately sometimes it's also to
our disability
that we are so fast and so efficient in
the way we design and you know in
singapore things moves very quickly
and the work that we do um in
participatory design
you you you actually have to slow it
down at the start
to get it right would you agree like you
actually spend a lot of time
hitting the ground talking and and and
then all of that
but the benefits of this has been all
seen and experienced
is that later on once you get that
sorted
you realize you have less reasons to
undo certain mistakes
i'm sure you're all being architects
have been even some of you might be
responsible for drawing beautiful
sketches you know waterfall in public
spaces a lot of children
playing and all of that and after it's
built it doesn't happen
all right so so i think this is what we
are
looking and trying to to share here
and uh king one you mentioned a little
bit maybe we just touched base some of
the questions about
measuring right so quite a few questions
uh
asking about that as well um like how do
you
ensure or or or or ensure success in the
long term
right one of the question is well the
particular residents participate in the
design execution process
who then maintain this long-term debut
um you know and what if they are cashes
there's quite a a
lot of questions um talking about
engaging the different views
of communities and we all had experience
where how do you do that how do you
balance the views of diverse communities
that
you have to engage um and especially i
think one of the questions that's asked
very early on with globalization
demographic makeup of singapore has
changed
how do we create new connections with
people that have different
different cultural backgrounds from us
so um
feel free um we talk a little bit about
how do you measure how you ensure a
longevity in the success of your project
and from there how do you build this new
connection
yeah well uh a great question
i think there's a multiple question
built into this one long question right
maybe i'll just answer one one of them
uh because
we are currently in our research we are
actually looking at
the idea of place keeping uh you know we
all know place making you know how to
make the place
but what we what we usually uh uh
i mean didn't really spend a lot of time
with is you know as designer we come in
do the place and then we leave and then
we
after five years we come back is it
still there right so
so this is something that we are really
investigating what what makes place
keeping work rather than just
place making and they actually take a
lot more extent
uh beyond the initial stakeholder but
stakeholders still is very important
but more important it deep down is
actually the culture
the culture of the group that is
actually that that we are helping
to motivate to to bring it into the
place and that culture will then
and ensure whether or not it's
sustaining or not that
that culture has to have a long-term
kind of vision
so that this place can be properly
sustained and maintained for the in the
long run
so so so that works uh hand in hand
uh stakeholder it's not just the people
who originally started the place
but it has to be connected with the
community at large
it has to connect it with the grassroot
it has connected to the cloud council
because many of those are public space
right so you really need to work very
closely with town council so that they
can also come into support
uh in terms of utility in terms of
maintenance cleanliness and all that
on the other hand uh if you are able to
slowly
empower the residents to actually slowly
taking over some of these maintenance i
think that will be our ideal
plan but i will be honest so far i don't
think we have really achieved that
so there's still some way to go and the
other one is resources
we also realized that many of this uh
you know project it started very well
because we put in the funds to do the
place making there after that
we you know the fun story like quite
often
who is going to get more money or more
manpower to continue that so you need to
have that
resources uh able to sustain that so
it's also stakeholder culture i think
all these come into play
and that's that's why it's not easy for
placemaking or for participatory design
per se
yeah i'd just like to jump in here to
give another
experience that we had in especially the
last
student based under flyover project that
we did
where the local government
corporator as we call them she was
on our side was helpful very supportive
not monetarily but in other ways
and she was very clear that
we should not have any seating spaces
because the drunk people will come and
sit down and make a mess
and but she attended the community
meeting that the students
shared their designs with where she said
no no no no sitting spaces
and in the same community design space
we had the seniors who were there who
said but actually we need
a space we carry our groceries and we
walk across and
where is the soft city where is the
humane city where i can sit for one
minute before i get back up
and so having these diverse viewpoints
aired in the same space uh of course as
a facilitator we have to take both
points of view and negotiate and
navigate it
in this case we try to design it in such
a way that people don't sleep there
that the fence that the locals put up
they lock in the night so nobody comes
in and hangs out and messes it up
so they found their own local ways of
sorting what their problems were but
it was important for each of them to
hear the other person's
viewpoint it is a problem for the
government to maintain such spaces
but it is a problem for the seniors who
need a spot to sit on
so just even listening to the other was
uh
problem solving in that case but with uh
place keeping uh kengua fabulous coining
uh self-critically a lot of our projects
do suffer in terms of place keeping
we kind of hand it over to the community
and the community tries to do the best
they can
but yeah we are not yet successful there
i think i think khamya and king were
really covered the point um
so i think i i totally agree with your
points um i think i probably would just
add on one more point on balancing
viewpoints
from different voices right i mean this
happens all the time i think in any
engagement
this happens all the time uh but from
the work we're doing pid
uh what what i have learned also is that
sometimes you know like what can't they
just not mention that you need to get
these viewpoints
into these people with different things
i mean differences in views to
really educate them you know this group
of people exist right and you guys have
to come to a common point or common
consensus
so you know in some instances whereby
for example just a simple thing of a
basketball court
we have residents who come down to this
design workshop just to make sure that
like yeah
i come here into this workshop with just
one purpose i want you guys to
take out the entire basketball court in
this whole renewal program
and and we're like okay you know um i'm
just saying at this viewpoint
but then at the same table you actually
have families and teenagers
who who actually are there to say like
you know what um
so i think as a facilitator it's really
our role to then you know okay i
understand you know uncle done that
you won the basketball court removed but
let's hear what the others have to say
and they then share this different
perspective from the neighborhood like
you know
this auntie will say yeah you know but i
do the zumba class here
every evening and if you take away this
basketball court can you take a look at
the map
you know where is the nearest massage or
open plaza i can do my zumba in
and they realize that the nearest one is
actually three blocks away
and that will take like 15 20 minutes
walk for a 60 year old
auntie you know and then that was when i
think that mr tan realized that
oh actually you know i shouldn't be
really so selfish
you know and he suddenly become very
quiet in the workshop because
he realized that like yeah you know i i
realize these points and and that is
very important because you bring the
conversations together
of these people with different
viewpoints and then they come to a
consensus right and then they would say
yeah then why not we design a basketball
court that could you know um
maybe reduce the noise so when we
actually you know play the basketball
court and the ball hit the ball
you know it would not create the noise
to disturb you right or we can give you
a shelter around the basketball court so
that you know can contain the noise
so you know wrestlers then come together
to brainstorm all these solutions
for town council to then resolve so so i
would say that you know these
conversations are very important so
i always tell our partners you know
don't be afraid of differing viewpoints
but
embrace them because you would rather
embrace it right now when you have a
chance to resolve it through
design then to actually resolve it later
when you have everything settled and
then all these complaints start coming
in you know
that is when you're in deeper trouble so
yeah so i really think that these
conversations are important to have
thank you i think um larry your last
point as well as king hua and kami
really really um share very concrete and
um
practical uh insights into what this
whole process is about right
um and and i cannot agree fully that you
know sometimes
you know i feel that when we we begin
these sessions you know
um often it's a letting ben
you know they come with oh great i can
tell you all my problems
you all solve it you know you guys are
the one who
will solve it for me right and they
leave
without actually realizing they are
involved in that whole thing and
when they realize that hey actually
the solution didn't come from somebody
being engaged to do this but they would
then they would just
hack right they actually like what come
here has talked about the civic
ownership
you know so so i think that is what is
really exciting and beautiful in this
view
because we can sense energy right and
you almost are like directors
of a play and and the community are the
actors in the state
however now one of the a few of the
questions as well to bring it back to
where we are currently in this asian
time
we have a pandemic going on and
all of our work you know whenever i get
out how's your work going i mean we deal
with community we deal with public
places
hmm challenging isn't it but that jokes
it's like um
really you know how do we see ourselves
or how do you treat your viewing because
of work
um see yourself able to continue uh
engaging with community uh connecting
and building you know projects or even
facilitating
um to get the project going in this time
and age
and quinoa um yourself as well you have
been
uh sharing and doubling quite a lot of
data and digital
some of the questions being asked is how
could we bring that
um online you know digital is it a
technology is it a a bane or a boon
right
like how can technology and all of us
have gone through zoom fatigue
you know this is my third zoom call
today but the fact is we have to do it
so very quickly how do you think this is
going to transform
the course of our work yeah yeah uh
maybe i can respond first uh
in the course of our work we also face a
lot of challenge
uh just like any of you here um
we don't have the kind of direct contact
with the user
anymore uh it's we actually try to
organize a couple of like uh you know
uh public space pop-up you know
so we can get some ideas and and
uh some kind of participation even small
group
everything is not allowed in fact we are
working very hard to
talk to town council to pa to uh various
stakeholder
uh to see how we can go around it but uh
right now i would say uh we're still in
the process
of you know finding ways to go around
because
we also see that with the online tools
uh it works to some extent uh because
it works for us because we uh you know
all having a smartphone we have a laptop
we have good wi-fi
but not many people are having that i
mean not all people
will have that right so especially when
we are working with
uh the uh those who are less privileged
i think then really the personal touch
is really really important
uh and we when we want to find uh you
know some of the questions i saw is
really good if we talk about systemic
issues
you know uh it it is hard
if you just want to uh do a poll
and then you just do a a
a street survey and then you expect to
actually dig out all these
uh issues at place i mean yes you can to
some extent actually we
in the research we did large scale or
small scale
survey or interview to sift out some of
these insights
uh but in order to effect the change it
it cannot be just remain at that
uh level of understanding or uh
or conversation i think conversation is
great but in order to effect
change you have to go at all levels so
stella just now i think you mentioned
that
uh people come into the session and walk
away realize that they they need to do
something i think that's very powerful
that's very important it's not about us
as a designer or community facilitator
to say that we have the power to change
no actually everyone has the power to
change
we need everyone to play the part
so the whole process is not about
empowering the designer to change
is that in fact it is empower the people
themselves
everyone me you know you and then see if
we are
all able to play a part that's where the
system can change
uh even if you want to uh you know
start from the top you know the the
the structural change in the policy
level also require the demand
from the support from the ground so so
we need to
as i think as facilitator i think larry
also
put it very rightly we are we see
ourselves as a media
mediator as a facilitator as a connector
between the different uh part of the
society right so we are able then to
navigate through
to get the architectural practitioner
involved
to get the policy maker involved to get
the committee
involved so that then it can have that
kind of systemic change if not
all these are just talks so uh
for one maybe i can share my own
personal view that
we have run a lot of focus group myself
included
but many of those focus groups may not
actually affect
much change yeah it feel good
but in the end we realize that but still
so what you know
so the real thing is then to work
on different level at the policy level
we need to be more critical
we need to really engage the different
stakeholders
uh including uh those who are in the
office
and then at the uh at the execution
level we really need
to work with those people who are
playing
the very critical role of running the
city
uh town council uh grassroots
these are our friends these are our
partners we really need to work hand in
hand with them because then we know
organizationally how we can effect those
change
and then at the people level we really
need to
connect them so that they also see the
multiple
views so yeah so that that's yeah
sorry takes too long no sorry i'm just
mindful of the time here
king i think attention uh one of the
questions as well you know ask about
that and given that many projects in
singapore would require some form of
involvement government agencies
right either they own the space or you
have to go through the stakeholders
to get approval to support a project or
to sustain it
you know one of the quick questions and
this time maybe i will direct it to
larry or come here or maybe larry
because it's
about singapore what is one key mindset
ship
you think is needed among public
officers
because we know that's so critical so
here stay
in your wish list and um
yeah actually i think it's a very
interesting question for me because
we do run workshops a lot with public
offices and
i think one thing i wish to actually say
to all the public officers out there who
is watching this
webinar i think it's really don't be
afraid to challenge the status quo
there's a lot of times i'm not sure
about karma how is it like overseas you
know
but in singapore i realized a lot of
public offices i don't blame them you
know because that's how
it's like you know we have to hit kpis
your bosses give you kpi
you're gonna meet it um and that's where
all this fear culture comes in you know
where affect my bonus wait for my job
would it affect my promotion
these are very practical concerns and i
did not blame the public officers
for having these concerts because that's
how our system groomed them to be
but moving forward as a nation and you
know as
as a whole singapore if we really want
to go beyond and really
start to have that empathy and
empowering citizens i think we need to
convince ourselves to think differently
do not be afraid to fail do not only try
things just because it is successful
elsewhere because
i can tell you if it is successful in
japan or in america
it doesn't mean that you'll be
successful in singapore so yeah
really just try you know it's okay to
make mistakes it's okay to fail
but that is what we should be as a
nation to improve and i really hope that
public officers out there
yeah have that you know confidence and
and be willing to try and adventure on
because uh
you know that is how participation is
and that is how you know citizen
engagement is like
so do not be afraid to try and i believe
kamiyah definitely you know overseas i'm
not sure how is it like but i think
probably maybe similar and i think it'll
be interesting to actually
hear from you yeah i think i think
public officers are people just like you
and me
uh they see city design
city making city keeping very
differently from us
because they know the real work that it
takes to make this function
right so honestly with our work we have
worked quite integrally with the
government wherever we go even in san
francisco even in india
and i have learned to listen to their
point of view as well and the minute you
listen to their pains and like larry you
said for the previous question
it's another set of diverse opinions
right so
the minute you can listen to their pain
points and see it from their view
and and then use your design skills to
even sort their problems out because
they're equally overwhelmed
uh public officers in the bangalore
context are equally overwhelmed with the
city and how to keep it running
so um yeah for me they are just another
really well-meaning community that need
to be equally listened to
as the others thank you yes thank you
yeah sorry i forgot to tie back to the
original question
about how we navigate through this
pandemic time
right so actually i was uh wanting to
see
say that right now instead of engaging
the community
directly actually what we can do and in
fact what we are doing now is to engage
the uh uh like what kind of has
mentioned the public officer
as well as the stakeholder uh all the
different organizations that exist in
the community
who are still running because they are
providing those services
so we work closely with vwos uh the
volunteer welfare organization
uh even uh with other uh you know
programs
uh that's run in those nearby
neighborhood like for example
we work in jurong east right now so we
work closely with the science center
so this other thing that you know we can
expand our scope
to see you know community is not just
the residents
but these are all the different
stakeholders that we can work with we
can still
you know have you know small meeting
with them and then to understand how we
can work with them
to reach out to the rest of the resident
so these are the word word never stop
thank you agree the work continues and
even more so during this time
um i'm very mindful that we're running
out of time and i have not forgotten
that you have one more
thing to present which is the task and
the exercise that i've shared and given
to all of you
and i'm very excited for you to share so
we have to do it very very quick
unfortunately so
everybody has got to do it like maybe 45
seconds to a minute max
all right so we started off this uh
webinar i asked um
everyone has to be mindful of these
three keywords design community home
and uh a lot of the the sharing so they
talk about very active things like
building
uh environment creating network and
connecting to the community
so you have 30 to 45 seconds
go
luckily i share a little bit just now
yeah so very simple yeah people space
and the way of design uh you know so in
in in a way that's how i see this three
uh
diagram will intersect and works and how
we can
connect people with space how we
co-create with people through design how
we call colon
between environment and design and how
we make use of all these things that you
know i
pop in like biodiversity cultural
diversity
knowledge material experience idea and
that's
where when everything in the set that
create
our sense of home okay larry
right thank you king paul mine is a
little bit i don't know what you can
make up it's actually a person
so for me i feel that community and home
are like our bodies you know it's like
our body
and our home is like our heart for me i
feel that they are part of a system
you know you can i mean your body can't
exist without a heart you know and your
heart can't exist without body so
just like how community at home is very
interconnected um that is how i actually
see
the connections and you know connection
building and create is like our blood
cells right basically
they keep the whole system going and and
this should be a continuous process you
know it shouldn't stop because once it
stopped
your body stopped functioning right your
community at home would not be able to
connect with one another
so i mean that's how i see all these
tools um as being the building block of
life
in a community and you know design is
actually where i feel the dna happens
because
they are actually inside your body but
you don't see them right i mean they may
seem so insignificant but
actually every day our life is
surrounded by design you know to the
bench you designed
the doorknob you know design that you
open every day to even the food that you
eat
you know all these are designed and we
don't see them but they're very
important like dna you know supporting
our body
so that's how i actually see you know
this whole participation design concept
you know
being invested in in this diagram you
know and
yeah that is my take on it awesome
thank you larry i love this
visualization
and lastly we have uh kamia
so mine i put in the diagram that i
showed you of the village
which was really like a heart beating it
had veins running through
it and like this pulsating organic
structure but home and the sense of home
is really
like i said initially peace and security
but
having just moved into my new home and
having set it up
that's not enough because then that's
just the house right
so the minute i started having
conversations with the neighbor
and she gives me like oh go to the store
close by it has this and
you know when you have those kinds of
more local connections
around you it's those networks and
connections for me
the the support structure the social net
around you that keeps you feeling secure
and peaceful
that really make this whole thing
meaningful and
participatory design co-designing with
people
makes that network really strong
and so that's kind of really what i seek
thank you
thank you so much and for those of you
who are watching
uh i hope this gives a very very good
wrapping
um and link us back to the idea the
question i asked at the beginning of
this conversation
what is your sense of home and what
makes your city loveable
and livable right and on that note
actually
we have another session coming up next
week uh
it's going to be moderated by my
co-founder adeep jalal interestingly
so please sign up it's a very good
session it's called to our city with
love
and here's the information for for the
sign up
and um for those of you who have been um
have some questions that have not been
done so
unfortunately we are running out of time
but rest assured that will be a
follow-up we have many many good
questions thank you
so much thank you for all your notes of
uh
sharing how your thoughts are it's very
very encouraging to us
as well and we'll definitely follow up
with um on an email
after this webinar okay um
and also finally we i want to just
continue to give a shout out
to archifest it actually starts tomorrow
if you have missed out on
some of the information king was a
festival director and archifest
is an amazing festival um
both adebe and myself have been involved
as well in two editions of this
and we are also going to be involved
this year
to be sharing on a a program called
knock knock is a community playbook
and uh so more details you can follow us
on shophouse
and co on our instagram and just go and
sign up go and find out more have
conversations we might be stuck at home
or we can't get in large groups but
ideas does not need to be contained in
physical space
conversations does not need to take
place
necessarily in a physical speech so
let's keep that going
let's keep the conversation going and i
thank you thank you my panelists it's
been a wonderful discussion larry
come here king hua i hope you had fun uh
promised to keep it a little bit you
know more relaxing
you know easy going and so um yeah we've
come to the end i have five more minutes
and i have to turn the session back to
amira
all right so thank you everyone thank
you thank you thanks everybody
thank you perfect thanks for that stella
and thank you to you and to all of our
wonderful speakers
so we've reached the end of today's
webinar and we hope everyone enjoyed the
conversations with exchange today
so before you leave you would love to
hear feedback on the webinar so what
should appear on your screen now is a qr
code
that will direct you to a very quick and
short post event survey
the link can also be found on the zoom
chat
so thank you once again to our wonderful
moderator stella and our panelists
kingmar larry and kanya and to all our
attendees thank you for sharing your
evening
with us have a good night and we hope to
see you very soon